you want to present yourself to the
world in a manner that doesn't disgrace
you in some sense that that might be a
good way to think about it you don't
want to disgrace yourself because the
consequence of disgrace is emotional
dysregulation more pain less positive
emotion and so the best way to present
yourself is to stand out forthrightly
and to stretch out you know and to
occupy some space and to make yourself
sort of vulnerable by doing that because
you open up the front of your body right
but it's a sign of confidence and that
way people are most likely to give you
the benefit of the doubt and that's a
good way to start regulating your mood
but not only does it directly regulate
your mood to stand up because so tightly
Associated like posture reflection is
associated with serotonin and emotional
regulation but also because if you
straighten up and you present yourself
in that manner then other people are
more likely to take you seriously and
that means they'll start treating you as
if you're a number one Lobster instead
of a number 10 Lobster and that's
another way that you can at least give
yourself the bloody benefit of the doubt
and confront the world in a courageous
manner standing up has changed my life
not just standing up for myself and
standing up for what I might believe in
and the the standing up what is it it's
not metaphysical the the the theoretical
I don't know but but actually standing
up like the physical standing up
going from sitting down like I am right
now in my car but to standing up has
changed my life stand-up desks are now a
huge uh Trend and a huge boost and and I
would definitely recommend checking some
of those out but when I first started
setting up was probably
wow I don't know maybe maybe 20 years
ago 15 years ago
I just found that when I was on the
phone and talking this is how it started
so I've been on I'm actually now on a my
office is a trampoline so I'm on a
stand-up trampoline desk I had to raise
my desk uh 10 inches so that the
trampoline could be underneath it and I
get 20 to 40 000 jumps a day on my
trampoline and went through three
trampolines last year because they broke
because most are not designed to be
jumped on that often but
trampolining while working might be a a
stretch for most people right now if you
ever see me and I'm doing an interview
and I'm on my main computer you might
see me
doing little micro bounces and I'm
trying to control it like hold it onto
the desk like don't bounce don't bounce
don't bounce because it can be it can be
annoying to watch on an interview but
for the most time I'm bouncing up and
down all day long on my trampoline now
why why did I start this well
15 20 years ago I just found that when I
was on the phone
and I was I was talking to clients I
would be better when I was walking
around
I don't know if it's a nervous energy or
what but when I sat down it was
less energetic less less like let's go
do this thing and when I when I stood up
it was just I had more energy
you could test yourself do you have more
energy when you're standing up or when
you're sitting down and so on calls I
would I would not just stand up but I
would walk around I like to have
something going on I often people
comment on some of my videos where I
fidget with my ring so my ring whenever
I'm thinking I like to be
I don't like to be meditative and still
I like to have something going on so I'm
often I'm often fidgeting with my ring
or you might see my ears move up and
down every now and then when I'm
thinking I like walking around just
having something go and it helps me
think and process better
and so that was the starting point was
just okay cordless phone and walk around
then I discovered a stand-up desk I
forget who it was it might have been Tim
Ferriss
again way back in the day and the the
test was not a full-on standard desk
because those barely existed but I took
my bookcase
and I cleared off the book and all the
books in the bookcase and I found the
shelf that was the kind of the best
height to put my laptop on and I just
tried standing there and I think this is
a good life hack not just for standing
up or not but just in general if you
want to try something
don't go off and buy the most expensive
thing and wait three weeks for it to be
delivered just go try something right
now
so if you want to try stand-up desks
don't go buy a stand-up desk don't do
that that's the worst thing you can do
don't spend a ton of money on a stand-up
desk and then wait three weeks for to be
delivered to you
just take a bookcase or take some boxes
and put it at the right height and see
how it feels
you want to start a YouTube channel
perfect don't don't go researching and
spend weeks buying the gear and the
lights and the cameras and all that
stuff and it most of that most of the
stuff in these little experiments end up
failing and they now you bought all this
gear that's just sitting in your garage
you know your closet or your mom's
basement
the best thing to do is just start find
a small way to just get started and so
I stood up at my bookcase and the first
day I didn't last very long 20 minutes
40 minutes I it didn't last very long
when you're not used to standing up it
it's really hard it's like oh where I
need to sit down and after that first 20
or 40 minutes I got tired and I had to
sit down because my body wasn't used to
it but while I was standing up like I
really like this this is cool I have
more energy in just answering emails and
whatever else I was doing at the time I
had more energy so I'm gonna try it
again and that 20 minutes became 30
minutes became 40 became two hours
became four hours became six hours to
the point was like I could just stand up
all day long it became weird when people
came over to my office because there
were no chairs to sit down at so when
we're doing a meeting I'm standing up
and so they were standing up because
there were no chairs and it felt awkward
to have one person standing one person
sitting and then they start getting
tired because after 20 minutes of
standing up you got tired so I had to I
had to bring chairs back to my office to
host meetings and
um but that was the process that was the
starting point and it it turned out to
have all sorts of positive health
benefits and I had I had
foot issues I had uh the things that you
put in your in your shoes what's it
called not implants uh customized Souls
whatever I was going to a car like in my
20s I was when a chiropractor almost
every week because my back was was a
mess my knees were were achy and
cracking every time I was walking like
my body seemed to be falling apart in my
20s I'm now 42 in May I'm 42 and my body
is in better condition than I was in my
20s
because a big I think a big factor is
because I'm on a trampoline all day long
instead of sitting all day long with
terrible posture and my body falling
apart now I'm jumping on the trampoline
all day long it's easy on my joints my
body I'm happy I have more energy and as
a result I'm healthier uh the move to a
trampoline came because I was I was
already standing up for
at least five years
uh maybe more and I saw Tony Robbins do
uh his his seminars and uh
backstage he would always jump before he
goes on stage Tony jumps a couple times
on his rebounder rebounder is just a
mini trampoline not like the giant
trampolines like what'd you have in your
backyard a rebounder is a mini version
of it that you can keep in your office
or your home or whatever he jumps a
couple times on his rebounder uh sprays
something in his mouth uh does like a
spin and then walks on stage
if you ever see him backstage that's
what he's always doing he jumps on his
trampoline a couple times puts something
in his mouth spins around goes out on
stage ready to go all right so that's
pretty cool I wonder what he's spraying
in his mouth uh and I like the whole
trampoline thing if I'm already standing
up why not get a trampoline and try and
so again what's what's the easiest way
to go off and do it well I I went to my
local Walmart and I bought a rebounder
and brought it home and
had to adjust the height of my desk and
had to raise it beyond what the max
height was and the rebounder I bought
ended up breaking shortly after because
it wasn't designed to be jumped on that
often all day long every day right but
whatever it's fine Lessons Learned right
you figure it out you think do is this
worth doing or not
take the idea that you've got and try
because again the biggest thing that
most people are missing is just momentum
you're just not trying you have this
you've had this idea and we spend our
best energy planning it and ideating and
researching and what's the perfect
trampoline and what's the perfect
stand-up desk and you spend all that
energy researching and then tomorrow you
wake up the next week you come back or
the next month or whatever like nothing
has happened on it still
you've all these great intentions but
there's not enough momentum
and so idea to action trust that your
ideas come to you for a reason and go do
something about them and so go get the
stand-up desk by creating boxes in your
office
now go get the cheapest trampoline at
Walmart and just jump on it and see how
it feels
it's ended up changing my life so
I'm not used to sitting down anymore uh
we actually moved we just sold our place
we bought a new place and I moved uh
into one of the rooms as a temporary
place while we were showing our place
because my office backdrop doesn't is
not very conducive to selling the house
most people are not used to a stand-up
desk a giant stand-up desk and
trampoline and all that and so I took my
office down because when you're selling
a home you wanted to appeal to everybody
and
I sat down for I don't know a couple
weeks while we were selling our place
and all of a sudden the back issues came
back I was cracking my back a lot my
knees started to hurt again my feet
started to hurt again my posture was
terrible again and I realized wow this
is why I stand up
so two lessons in this video the first
is try standing up
yeah you'll probably have more energy
you'll probably feel better it's
probably better for your health people
say sitting is the new smoking right so
try standing up and just give it a shot
and don't stress out if you get tired
after 20 minutes like I did the first
time through it's okay but do you have
more energy while you're working while
you're standing up and if so then just
keep going and just start with a
bookshave for some bookshelves uh or
some boxes whatever just to get started
and the second lesson is is just do
something just momentum imperfect action
the ideas that you have in your head are
great they're genius you need to do
something you need to stop putting the
gas pedal on the energy that's flowing
through you like greatness is flowing
through you you're actively saying stop
stop stop do something find the smallest
possible way today today like right now
the smallest possible way to take that
awesome idea in your head and build some
momentum towards it
because the only thing you're missing
towards your great life is the momentum
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there
it is my firm belief that each of us
have a responsibility to set the world
right in the manner that we are able to
and that that is a
fundamental
that's a fundamental import I really
believe in some sense it's of cosmic
import
in the same way that Consciousness
itself is of cosmic import and
Consciousness reflects being itself you
arrived in the book there is no faith
and no courage and no sacrifice in doing
what is expedient
what do you say to those viewers that
don't pursue their dreams and are locked
into their careers because they are too
afraid to take risks and pursue
something meaningful well the first
thing I would say is well you should be
afraid of taking risks and pursuing
something meaningful
but you should be more afraid of staying
where you are if it's making you
miserable it's like the first thing you
want to do is dispense with the idea
that you get to have any any permanent
security outside of your ability to
contend and adapt it's the same issue
with children it's like you're paying a
price by sitting there being miserable
and you might say well the devil I know
is better than the one I don't it's like
don't be so sure of that the clock is
ticking and if you're miserable in your
job now and you change nothing in five
years you'll be much more miserable and
you'll be a lot older but isn't it a
luxury to pursue what is Meaningful our
viewers have mortgages they have
children they have payments and Loans
it's a luxury to pursue because we lack
the resources well I don't think I don't
remember now I'm not talking about what
makes you happy
it's a luxury to pursue what makes you
happy it's a moral obligation to pursue
what you find meaningful and that
doesn't mean it's easy it might require
sacrifice if you need to change your job
too let's say you have a family and and
and children and a mortgage you have
responsibilities
you've already picked up those
responsibilities you don't just get to
walk away scot-free and say well I don't
like my job I quit that's no strategy
but what you might have to do is you
think well this job is killing my soul
all right so what do I have to do about
that well I have to look for another job
well no one wants to hire me it's like
okay maybe you need to educate yourself
more maybe you need to update your your
curriculum Vita your resume maybe you
need to overcome your fear of being
interviewed maybe you need to sharpen
your social skills like you you have to
think about these things strategically
if you're going to switch careers you
have to do it like an intelligent
responsible person that might take you a
couple of years of of of effort I've
dealt with hundreds of people in my
clinical and Consulting practice and we
set a goal we develop a vision and work
towards it and it things inevitably get
better for people so it's not a luxury
it's it's difficult it's a moral
responsibility and it isn't happiness
it's it's not the pursuit isn't for
happy well that isn't how it is it's
like we're built for struggle us human
beings not after
um the bubbles of bliss that Dostoevsky
described in in Notes from Underground
were built to contend with the world
we're built to contend with reality you
want to challenge and the best way that
you can take on a challenge because a
challenge fortifies you so you don't
want to be secure you want to be strong
and you get strong by taking on optimal
challenges and so you lay out your
destiny in the world and you take the
slings and arrows of fate and you make
yourself stronger while you're doing so
and you might fail and Fortune might do
you in but it's your best bet and you
know people have also people that have
extracted unbelievable successes out of
catastrophic failures and so and I'm not
saying that in a naive way I know
perfectly well what happens to people
you know you're doing fine in life and
then you get cancer and then six months
later you're dead and all the heroism in
the world isn't going to save you at
that point but that's not the point
that's not the point life is bounded by
mortality but that doesn't mean that you
don't get out there and contend and you
develop by contending and you minimize
the net amount of suffering in the world
and that's something man that's
something to do compare yourself to who
you were yesterday and not to who
someone else is today
uh because if you're comparing yourself
to someone else I mean first of all you
don't know very much about the life of
the person you're comparing yourself to
you don't know and it know it across all
of its dimensions and second people are
very different and so comparing yourself
to someone else
it's it's kind of useful I guess when
you're young but as you get older and
more singular and more particular it
becomes increasingly less useful better
to compare yourself to a previous
version of yourself and work for
improvement in that way life is
difficult and you cannot protect your
children
what you can do is prepare them and you
can prepare them to be strong and
courageous and truthful and resilient
and reciprocal in their interactions
with other people and that means you
equip them for what life will be which
is at minimum a series of difficult
challenges and and often more than that
because of course people go through very
difficult times in their lives and
a resilient person is capable of
standing up to things in the face of
fear and moving forward voluntarily
convinced of their own competence and
ability to Prevail and so the primary
your primary goal as a parent apart from
facilitating your child's social
desirability which is a major
obligation on your part is to encourage
your children and to and I mean that
literally to instill in them a sense of
courage in the face of the difficulties
of life and not to protect them from
that we don't even want to be protected
from those difficulties because a major
part of life and its meaning is the
the challenge that comes with
confronting difficulties I said with
Bill c-16 that I wouldn't speak the
language of the radical leftists because
I don't think that that language should
Define the game but let's say it does so
here's the game
the world is a battleground of groups
and the they're battling for power
that's it that's the game and some of
them win and they oppress those who
don't win so that's how we're going to
view the world
okay now the left is say okay well
here's the oppressed people the
oppressors
the patriarchy type patriarchal types
they should be ashamed of themselves and
give up some power
the right Wingers the radical
right-wingers look at that and they say
oh I see so the game is ethnic identity
is it it's it's identity politics okay
we're white males
we're not going to lose
that's the right-wing version of
identity politics it's like screw you
if we're going to divide into groups if
we're going to divide into tribes
and I'm in my tribe I'm not going to get
all guilty and lose
I'm going to get all cruel and win
and that's like then you think well
there's people in the middle they're
kind of looking back and forth which
side of the identity politics Spectrum
am I going to fall in do I want to go
with uh do I want to go do I want to be
driven primarily by compassion and am I
going to accept guilt for my historical
privilege so that's one possibility and
then I'm the oppressor I'm the member of
the oppressor group or am I going to say
oh no to Hell Without I'm just going to
play to win well then I'm going to go to
the right it's like well my sense is how
about we don't play either of those
games and the reason we shouldn't play
them is well the Soviets played the
left-wing game and like killed who knows
how many tens of millions of people you
can't even count it accurately the
estimates range from 20 to 100 million
those are pretty big error bars and the
maoists maybe a hundred million
certainly 60 million
so okay that didn't work out so well
then there's the Nazis like they played
ethnic identity politics and racial
superiority it's like why do we want to
play that game
see what I've been trying to do really
what I've been trying to do for the last
30 years is say look
there's heavy Temptations to play those
sorts of games
but that's not the only game in town
it's a much better game to play
individual it's like get your act
together
stand up in the world make something of
yourself stay away from the ideological
oversimplifications set your house in
order that's rule six in the in the in
this book so I have a book rule in there
says set your house in perfect order
before you criticize the world and it's
a very dark chapter about the
motivations of the Columbine High School
killers and this other guy named Carl
panzram who is a serial rapist and
arsonist and murderer and these he wrote
an autobiography and the Columbine kids
also wrote about why they did what they
did they're resentful to the core bitter
bitter resentful terrible
and
well I'm suggesting that people stay
away from that resentment resentfulness
and bitterness even though life is hard
and and there's malevolence in the world
it's like yeah you can you can tell a
story where everyone's a victim because
we all die we all get sick
you know and and and things happen to us
that are
bitter and terrible betrayal deceit lies
like people hurt us on purpose you know
so it's not just the tragedy of life
its malevolence as well it's everyone's
a victim you can tell that story the
problem is if you tell that story and
you start to act it out you make all of
that worse that's the problem
and it's so this is why partly I got
attracted to Christian imagery at least
in part
um because there's an idea in
Christianity that you should pick up
your God cross and like walk up the hill
and that's
dramatically that's correct
that's the right answer it's like
you've got a heavy load of suffering to
bear and a fair bit of it's going to be
unjust so what are you going to do about
it accept it voluntarily and try to
transform as a consequence that's the
right answer it's the right answer
because the rest of it is tribalism and
we're we're too technologically possible
the baboon here who's supposed to be
basically just a fool when the story was
first written he turned into what's
essentially a shaman across time and so
he represents the self from the union
perspective now the self is everything
you could be across time so imagine that
there's you and there's the potential
inside you whatever that is you know and
potential is an interesting idea because
it's represents something that isn't yet
real yet we act like it's real because
people will say to you you should live
up to your potential and that potential
is partly what you could be if you
interacted with the world in a manner
that would gain you the most information
right because you build yourself out of
the information in the piagetian sense
but it's deeper than that too because we
know that if you take yourself and you
put yourself in a new environment new
genes turn on in your nervous system
they encode for new proteins and so
you're full of biological potential that
won't be realized and unless you move
yourself around in the world into
different challenging circumstances and
that'll turn on different circuits so
it's not merely that you're
incorporating information from the
outside world in the constructivist
sense it's that by exposing yourself to
different environments you put different
physiological demands on on yourself all
the way down to the genetic level and
that manifests new elements of you and
so one of the things that happens to
people and this is a very common
cultural notion is that you should go on
a pilgrimage at some point to somewhere
Central and that would be say like The
Rock in The Pride Rock in The Lion King
because you take yourself out of your
Dopey little village and that's just a
little bounded you that everyone knows
and that isn't very expanded and then
you go somewhere dark and dangerous to
the central place and while you do that
you have adventures and they toughen you
and pull more out of you and dual
familial and social harmony
that's what I want people say that to me
and you know I don't think it's exactly
right there's there's a line in the Old
Testament the fear of God is the
beginning of wisdom and I think it's
more like that it's not that I'm
courageous it's that I'm afraid of the
right things
so when I made my videos it wasn't like
that didn't make me nervous
but I was less nervous about going back
to bed and not saying what I had to say
than I was about making the videos
because I know where this is going
I don't want to go there and so
it's it's not so much courage it's that
it's a matter of
I it's it's it's less risky to say
something
than to remain silent when you know
there's something to be said I know that
to be the case and so lots of times in
life it's like there's no pathway
forward that's going to Shield you from
risk you get to pick this risk or you
get to pick this risk and I think I
picked the Lesser risk and that might be
wise but I'm not so sure it's courageous
you don't tell your kid here's an
impossible thing why don't you go out
and fail you say here's something worth
going after here's a step you could take
that would push you beyond where you are
but that you also have a reasonably high
probability of succeeding at right they
called that within a time frame within
some time frame that's the other thing
you have to parameterize it with regards
to time frame that's right and that puts
you in the zone of proximal development
and that's a that's a concept that was
generated by a guy named vygotsky he was
a Russian developmental psychologist and
a smart one it's where the idea of the
Zone comes from to be in the zone and
when you're in the zone you're expanding
your skills
at in a manner that's intrinsically
rewarding because you're succeeding and
so you want to set if you're good to
yourself you think okay I need to set a
goal but I need to set a goal that
someone as stupid and useless as me
could probably attain if they put some
effort into it right and then you go
then you've got it perfectly because
it's not so high that it's grandiose or
impossible that you fail necessarily and
then justify your bitterness it's like
well I couldn't do well because that
happens to people happens all the time
yeah it's like this all the time you
know it's like it's yes exactly well I
set a goal and I didn't attain it so I'm
not going to set any more goals right
it's like no you set a goal that was
inappropriate for the time frame that's
right you didn't calibrate it properly
and and you're playing a trick on
yourself because you wanted to fail so
that you could justify not having to try
that's why I'm being a victim yeah which
isn't helpful you're still going to be a
victim it's like there's no way out of
that man so you know because life is
this life is a challenge that in some
sense can't be surmounted so there's no
way out of your problem not only you
have to move from point A to B in life
but point A is often a very difficult
place to be because we're fragile and
bounded and mortal and limited and
because we know that and so one of the
implications of that as many great
religious Traditions are at pains to
illustrate or demonstrate or Proclaim is
that life is essentially suffering
and I believe that to be a fundamental
truth but
but perhaps not the most fundamental
truth because I think the most
fundamental truth is that despite the
fact that life is suffering people can
transcend that and partly the way they
transcend that is by pursuing things of
value and so that if there is no value
proposition at hand then you have no
meaning to justify the difficult
conditions of your life and that's
brutally difficult for people no
Nietzsche said he who has a why can bear
any how
and you see and I've certainly seen this
as a clinical practitioner that people
who have no purpose in their life
are embittered by the difficulties of
their life and they become first bitter
and then resentful and then revengeful
and then cruel and there's plenty of
places to go past cruel that's just
where you start if you're really on a
downhill path the more radical the
necessary change the more pain that
accompanies it like the more opportunity
as well
but and a lot of what we learn we learn
painfully and so it's not surprising
that people shrink away from learning we
learn in pain and anxiety very
frequently everyone knows that like the
things that really that you really
learned in life it's like it was no joy
man like it took you out and so the fact
that people flee from that is hardly
surprising
but it doesn't help that's the thing it
just stores up the catastrophe for later
and so the better the better ideas to
eat a little Poison every day so that
you don't have to overdose in a month
it's something like that
and it is the case that I think because
you don't you aren't forced first of all
you don't learn unless you're forced to
learn I know there's alternatives to
that there's the voluntary search for
knowledge and that's a fine thing and
that is an antidote to this but
apart from that speaking more
practically
you tend not to learn unless you're
forced to learn and it's and what you
tend to learn by force are difficult
lessons and so people are very prone to
not
do not seek that out it's not surprising
but it's because they don't understand
the consequences very well
you know you you
it's because maybe it's because they're
convinced that there's some way of
forestalling the necessary learning and
there isn't
any way of forestalling it all you do is
make it worse in the future you make
yourself smaller and you make the lesson
harder
and so that's why in So Many religious
doctrines there's emphasis on humility
you know and humility isn't to debase
yourself
it's to understand that
you don't know enough so that your life
isn't going to be miserable
and so every chance you get to grab
something new that will help you along
your way you should take it as fast as
you can but you have to have a very
tragic
I would say view of reality and also a
harsh one because it's not just tragedy
it's also malevolence you have to
understand that those are waiting for
you and that makes you desperate enough
to learn and that might be make you
desperate enough to fall out of your
ideology but
that's that's a hard way of looking at
the world
it beats living through it though one of
the things I've been talking to my
audiences about is the relationship
between responsibility and meaning which
is what would you say it's a it's a
constant refrain in the book it's one of
its underlying
messages let's say or
themes is a better way of thinking about
it
um
you know if you start with the
presumption that there's a baseline of
suffering in life and that that can be
uh exaggerated by as a consequence of
human failing as a consequence of
malevolence and betrayal and
self-betrayal and deceit and all those
things that we do to each other and
ourselves that we know that aren't good
that amplifies the suffering that's sort
of the Baseline against which you have
to work and and and it's contemplation
of that often that makes people hopeless
and depressed and anxious and
overwhelmed and all of that and and they
have the reasons but you need something
to put up against that and what you put
up against that is meaning meaning is
actually the Instinct that helps you
guide yourself through that catastrophe
and most of that meaning is to be found
in the adoption of responsibility
so if you think for example if you think
about the people that you admire well
you think about when you have a clear
conscience first because that's a good
thing to aim at which is something
different than happiness right
um a clear conscience is different than
happiness yeah it's better yeah that's
better guilting yourself you're not
feeling bad about yourself that's right
you feel that you've Justified you've
Justified your existence right and so
you're not waking up at three in the
morning in a cold sweat thinking about
all the terrible things that you've
involved yourself in what you said to
someone that you shouldn't have said or
how you acted or what opportunity you
lost or or or or yeah or or the things
that you've that you've let go that you
should have capitalized on and all of
that and so if you think about the times
when you're at peace with yourself with
regards to how you're conducting
yourself in the world it's almost always
conditions under which you've adopted
responsibility right at least the most
the most guilt I think that you can
experience perhaps is the sure knowledge
that you're not even taking care of
yourself so that you're leaving that
responsibility to other people because
that's pretty pathetic and I unless
you're Psychopathic and you know and
you're living a parasitical life and
that that characterizes a very small
minority of people and an even smaller
minority think that's justifiable but
most of the time you're in guilt and
shame because you're not you're you're
not
not only are you not taking care of
yourself let's say so someone else has
to but you're not living up to your full
potential and so there's a existential
weight that goes along with that you
know we kind of have this idea that
while you're free as a child and then
you
let me see if I can if I can put this
properly that you have a certain
delightful wonderful positive Freedom as
a child and then that's given up as you
approach adulthood but the truth of the
matter is is that
you have a lot of potential as a child
but none of that is capable of
manifesting itself as Freedom before you
become disciplined
and discipline is a matter of the
imposition of order and the order is
necessary especially for people who are
hopeless and nihilistic and lots of
people are hopeless and nihilistic way
more people than you think and part of
that is because no one's ever really
encouraged them and so the book is in
part a matter of encouragement it's like
lay yourself lay a disciplinary
structure on yourself get the chaos in
in check and then you can move towards
the state that's Freer because it's
disciplined first like look if you're
going to become a concert pianist
there's going to be several thousand
hours of extraordinarily disciplined
practice that's the imposition of order
on your potential let's say but what
comes out of that is a much grander
Freedom your best bet is truth
but that doesn't necessarily mean that's
always going to do the trick
right I mean sometimes
you go fight a dragon and it eats you
and if the if you being eaten wasn't a
real possibility it wouldn't be a real
fight
and so you see people like I've seen
people
in my clinical practice sometimes
I had one client in particular who was
undergoing a particularly vicious
divorce with someone who is really
seriously inclined to take him out and
would do pretty much everything at her
disposal to do so and I strategized with
him for about three years
and we did everything like and Hyper
carefully he was a very conscientious
and diligent person and he put into
practice everything that we discussed
and strategized and he still pretty much
he got back into a corner so hard that I
didn't know how to help him anymore
so
I would say however that he like he was
a very truthful person throughout that
and one thing he did do was
part of it was a custody battle
and he did manage despite his decline
in consequence of being repeatedly
cornered I would say he did manage to
establish what I think was a lasting
relationship with his kids
so he might have got enough out of what
he did to justify it even though the
whole landscape was pretty awful
I think that not lying is your best bet
but life is hard and people get run over
and it doesn't necessarily mean that
you're going to emerge in any obvious
sense triumphant
but if you take the alternative past
path especially when you're
facing severe tribulations let's say and
you complicate those with deceit you can
be sure that whatever tragedy that
you're confronting is going to turn into
not only tragedy but something very much
akin to hell
and so you might be able to at least
minimize the degree of suffering even if
you can't
overcome it or transcend it well before
the political stuff blew up I had a
million views on YouTube which is
nothing a million of anything is a lot
but then when the political Scandal
started to break yeah then people came
for them but stayed for the content and
so and that's very useful yeah well it's
fine well and it's not that surprising
well you know because of what you do
it's like
there's a great hunger for information
that is practical and useful and that
helps people find meaning in their lives
and Orient themselves there's a great
hunger for that and most of my lectures
were derived from
solid psychology some of it experimental
some of it biological some of it from
from from the domains of Neuroscience a
lot of it from Great clinicians it's not
surprising that people find it helpful
because well great clinicians were great
because they were really helpful and so
to distill that and to offer it to
people in a digestible form to have that
have a good effect on them well that's
that's what you'd expect that's what the
whole discipline is about and so that's
been that's been great the
circumambulation that Jung talked about
was this continual we'll return to this
this continual circling in some sense of
who you could be you might notice for
example that there are themes in your
life you know when you go back across
your experiences you see you kind of
have your typical experience that sort
of repeats itself and there might be
variation on it like a musical theme but
it's it's like you're circling yourself
and getting closer to yourself as you
move across time that's the
circumambulation now you remember that
for a sec because we'll go back to it
okay so imagine that something glimmers
before you it's an interest that's
Dawning and you decide well first of all
you're paralyzed you think well how do I
know if I should pursue that it's
probably a stupid idea and the proper
response to that is you're right it
probably is a stupid idea because almost
all all ideas are stupid and so the the
probability that as you move forward on
your adventure that you're going to get
it right the first time is zero it's
just not gonna happen and so then you
might think well maybe I'll just wait
around until I get the right idea and
which people do right so they're like 40
year old 13 year olds which is not a
good idea so they wait around until it's
waiting for Godot until they finally got
it right but the problem is you're too
stupid to know when you've got it right
so waiting around isn't going to help
because even if it the perfect
opportunity manifested itself to you in
your incomplete form the probability
that you would recognize it as the
perfect opportunity is zero you might
even think it's the worst possible idea
that you've ever heard of anywhere
highly likely highly likely so so you
have there's Nietzsche called that a
will to stupidity which I really liked
so because he thought of stupidity as
being it you know it's it's you have to
take it into account fundamentally and
work with it and so and so you can take
these tentative steps on your pathway to
Destiny and you can assume that you're
going to do it badly and that's really
useful because you don't have to beat
yourself up it's pretty easy to do it
badly
but the thing is it's way better to do
it badly than not to do it at all you
start your path and you think that
you're heading you know towards your
star
and so you go in that direction and then
because
you're here the world looks a particular
way but then when you move here
the world looks different and you're
different as a consequence of having
made that voyage and so what that means
is that now that thing that glimmers in
front of you is going to have shifted
its location because you weren't very
good at specifying it to begin with and
now that you're a little sharper and
more focused than you were it's it's
going to reveal itself with more
accuracy to you and so then you have to
take a
you know it's almost like 180 degree
reversal but it isn't because you know
you've
I mean you've gone this far and that's a
long ways to get that far
but that's a lot farther than you would
be if you just stayed where you were
waiting
and so it doesn't matter that you
overshoot continually
because as you overshoot
even if you don't learn what you should
have done you're going to continually
learn what you shouldn't keep doing
and if you learn enough about what you
shouldn't keep doing then that's
tantamount at some point to learning at
the same time what you should be doing
so it's okay
so it's like this
now what's cool about it though I think
is that as you progress the degree of
overshooting starts to decline right and
that we know that there's nothing
hypothetical about that as you learn a
new skill like even to play play a song
on the piano for example you overshoot
madly you're making all sorts of
mistakes to begin with and then the
mistakes
they they disappear the fact that you're
full of faults doesn't mean you have to
stop
and thank God for that that's a really
useful thing and the fact that you're
full of faults doesn't mean that you
can't learn
and so you can pause it an ideal and
you're going to be wrong about it but it
doesn't matter because what you're right
about is positing the ideal moving
towards it if the actual ideal isn't
conceptualized perfectly well first
surprise surprise because like what are
you going to do that's perfect so it
doesn't matter that it's imperf
imperfect it just matters that you do it
and that you move forward so that's
really that's really positive news as
far as I'm concerned because you can
actually do that right you can do it
badly anyone can do that so that's
that's useful I'm incredibly nervous to
uh talk in front of you because you've
got to be one of the most formidable
people that I've ever heard of or ever
listened to or ever seen so
my question is again you're one of the
best communicators that I've ever
listened to
if I could be
half as good at you or at communicating
As You Are
I would be set how can I teach myself to
do that practice
you know really like
well there's a couple of things
to read
a lot
it really helps to write
so if you want to make yourself
articulate
which is a very good idea
then not only should you read but you
should write down what you think
and if you can do that a little bit
every day
15 minutes maybe you could steal 15
minutes and do it every day
but if you do that for 10 years you
really straighten out your thinking
if you're going to speak
effectively
you have to know way more than you're
talking about you know so if you this is
often difficult for beginning lectures
at the University because they'll do a
lecture on a topic but they only know as
much as they're saying in the lecture
and they get kind of stuck to their
notes because of it but you want to know
10 times as much as you are saying in
the lecture and then you can
specify a stepping path through it and
elaborate with the other things that you
know but to do that you have to do a lot
of reading but you also have to do a lot
of reading because that's where the
synthesize that's where the synthesizing
comes
so that's on the input side and then on
the output side well there's some tricks
techniques let's say is like if you're
speaking in front of a group you are not
delivering a talk to a group
that's not what you're doing the talk
isn't a package thing that you present
to a group there isn't a group
there's a bunch of individuals
and you talk to them so when I talk to a
group I always talk to people one at a
time and that makes it easier too
because you know how to talk to a person
it's like can you talk to a thousand
people well probably not because it's
too intimidating but there isn't a
thousand people there there's
a thousand individuals and so you just
look at an individual and you say
something and you can tell if they're
engaged
they look confused or they look
interested or they look angry or they
look bored or maybe they're asleep in
which case you look at someone else
and they give you feedback about how
you're doing and so one thing is to to
have something to say yeah but the next
thing is pay attention to who you're
talking to Because unless you're very
badly socialized then that seems
unlikely in your case because you know
you present yourself at least moderately
well you know and well I mean I don't
know you very well but in first but on
First Sight you know you're doing fine
so the probability that if you pay
attention to the individuals that you're
talking to that your natural
wealth of of social skill will manifest
itself is extremely high and so you
don't deliver a talk to an audience
that's a really bad way of thinking
about you're actually engaged in a
conversation with an audience even if
they're not talking they're nodding and
shifting position and you know looking
like this or and you can you can pull
all that in and and use it to govern the
level at which you're addressing the
entire audience so
the last thing I would say is well
having the aim to be a good communicator
is a good start and you think well I
could buttress that to some degree
there isn't anything that you can
possibly this is the whole point of a
liberal education there isn't anything
that you can possibly do that makes you
more competent
in everything you do than to learn how
to communicate I don't care if you're
going to be a carpenter I mean being a
carpenter by the way is very difficult
especially if you're a good Carpenter
but if you're good at communicating as a
carpenter you're like 10 times better as
a carpenter
so the and this is something that the
liberal arts colleges I think I don't
know if they've forgotten it but they
don't do a very good job of marketing
it's like what's the use of a bachelor's
degree a Bachelor of Arts it's like well
you can think you can write you can
speak you've read something
it's like
the economic value of that is
incalculable the people that I've
watched in my life have been
spectacularly successful are they have
skills
clearly that that's a
minimum precondition but they're also
very very good at articulating
themselves and so whenever they
negotiate they're successful
well that's kind of like the definition
of success in life right you negotiate
and you're six it doesn't mean you win
because if you're a good negotiator if
you're a really good negotiator
everybody walks away from the
negotiation thrilled
and so then people line up to do things
with you
so and that's all that's all dependent
on your ability to communicate so
practice oh yes chapter nine is assume
that the person you are listening to
might know something you don't
this is a chapter about conversation and
about the different forms conversation
takes
it's a chapter about humility
and it's a chapter about listening and
the humility element is it took me a
long time to understand why there's
religious injunctions supporting
humility
to even understand what the word really
meant in that sort of technical sense
and it means something like this it
means what you don't know is more
important than what you know
and that's a lovely thing to then then
what you don't know can start to be your
friend you see people are very defensive
about what they know and for the reasons
we've already discussed but the thing is
you don't know enough and the re you can
tell you don't know enough because your
life is not what it could be and neither
is the life of the people around you you
just don't know enough and so what that
means is that every time you encounter
some evidence that you're ignorant
someone points it out you should be
happy about that because you think oh
you just told me how I'm wrong it's like
great like maybe I had to sift through a
lot of nonsense to get through the real
message that you're telling me but if
you could actually tell me some way that
I'm wrong and then maybe give me a hint
about how to not be wrong like that well
then I wouldn't have to be wrong like
that anymore that that would be a good
thing and you can you can you can embark
on that Adventure by listening to people
and if you listen to people they will
tell you
they'll tell you amazing things if you
listen to them and many of those things
are little tools that you can put in
your toolkit like Batman and then you
can go out into the world and use those
tools and you don't have to fall blindly
into a pit quite as often and so the
humility element is well
do you want to be right
or do you want to be learning
and then it's deeper than that it's do
you want to be the the tyrannical King
who's already got everything figured out
or do you want to be the continually
transforming hero or fool for that
matter who's getting better all the time
and that's actually a choice you know
um it's a deep choice and it's better to
be the self-transforming fool who's
humble enough to make friends with what
he or she doesn't know and to listen
when people talk and listening is a
transformative exercise like if if you
listen to the people in your life for
example if you actually listen to them
they'll tell you what's wrong with them
and how to fix it and what they want
they can't even help it if you start
listening because people are so shocked
if you actually listen to them that they
they tell you all those sorts of things
that they might not have even intended
to things they don't even know and then
you can you can work with that but our
topic is
the rising tide
of compelled speech in Canada
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
that's pure narcissism at work by the
way
[Applause]
yeah
you don't want to hijack to hijack an
event like this
that other people put time and effort
into and to use they their their
civility of the crowd and the civility
of the organizers as an excuse to
blatantly yell out your ill-informed
opinions there's no way to conduct a
civil dialogue these people
are not your friends
[Music]
[Applause]
let me see you know
that's that that and mark my words
that's the sounds of the barbarians
pounding at the gates
right
yeah that's I'll I'll tell you again too
that use of
in Kuwait
[Music]
what would you call it in Kuwait
sensation is the best formulation of
their argument
and there's not much difference between
knocking on the doors and knocking on
you
so keep that in mind
it's not amusing there's nothing to it
there's nothing for it the thing that's
also quite appalling is that there's no
evidence whatsoever that the people who
are conducting these protests know what
it is that they're protesting against
you know I was in
[Applause]
I I was in the midst of a discussion
attempting to make the case that
it's freedom of speech that's that is
what people who have nothing still have
right so if you look at the tyrannical
structure of our society let's say the
people at the top have access to means
of communication everyone knows that
it's the people at the bottom who have
the right to say what they think however
badly they say it that enables them to
get a Toe Hold into the system and to
and to make their suffering known that's
what freedom of speech is for and so
like what's the protest against that and
I'll tell you you know that the radical
neo-marxis types they speak the language
of power and that's what they're
speaking right now and if you want to
live in a world where everyone speaks
the language of power then just let them
do what they're doing and see what
happens I wouldn't recommend it it's not
a pretty Road and you're all in a
position you're on a situation in your
life now where you have to make
decisions about these sorts of things
like is this the sort of institution
that you want this to be I do believe
it's the case because I've watched
people do very difficult things like
people who work in palliative care
Awards so all they're ever dealing with
is pain and death right and they can do
it I get up in the morning they go to
work and they take care of those people
they lose people on a weekly basis and
yet they can do it and what that shows
is that if you turn around and you
confront the suffering voluntarily you
find out that you are way tougher than
you think it's not that life is better
than you think life is as harsh as you
think it might even be worse but you are
way tougher than you think if you turn
around and confront it and so then what
you discover is that there's a spirit
within you that pursues that can pursue
something meaningful that has the
resilience and the strength to contend
properly with the catastrophe of
existence without becoming bitter that's
actually the central so and then I would
say that's one of the central themes of
12 rules for life is that make no
mistake about it like the first Noble
Truth of Buddhism life is suffering this
is true and it's worse than that because
it's suffering contaminated by
malevolence that's the Baseline but and
so that's very pessimistic but the
optimistic part is that you are so tough
if you can actually not only deal with
that you can improve it it's like oh
well that's a horrible situation but it
turns out that I'm armed for the task
well that's that's a great thing for
people to know and I do believe I think
the fact that we're armed for the task
is even more true than the fact that
life is catastrophe contaminated by
malevolence we're stronger than things
are terrible so and things are pretty
terrible so that means we're pretty damn
strong wow yes it's a very good thing to
know and it's not naive optimism it's a
very different thing it's like no things
are terrible they're brutal and you are
so tough you can't believe it you love
to quote this line This Nietzsche line
that all anyone who has a why to live
for can endure almost any hell yeah
what's your why what is driving you you
see when people read history they they
either read it as a detached Observer or
they tend to read it as
well maybe the heroic the heroic
protagonist people like to imagine that
they would be Schindler in Schindler's
List but that's wrong
so because the probability that you'll
be the perpetrator is much higher
especially merely the perpetrator who's
in sconced in silence when silence is
not the appropriate thing
so I wanted to having figured out what
constituted hell and the pathway to that
which would be I suppose the cowardice
that produces
the cowardice and resentment that
produces either complicitness in those
events or failure to oppose them when
they emerge I wanted to understand what
the opposite of that was
because I think that's what needs to be
learned from what happened in the 20th
century and so that's why I wrote maps
of meaning was to understand that and to
lay out what the opposite was
and then that turned out to be extremely
helpful to me and then to the people I
started to teach about that because
it's useful to know what the opposite of
hell is and I've been teaching those
things to people since 1993. so that's
25 years and the response from the
students has always been the same sort
of response that I'm getting now
absence some of the negative
characterizations let's say which which
have emerged for particular reasons but
the students have always said one of two
things
and and this is the vast majority of
them this isn't cherry-picked responses
it's been the same everywhere
um
they tell me and this is the same
response I get from my audiences now too
is they say you've given me words to
explain things to explain and understand
things that are always new to be true
or
I was in a very dark place for one of
the seven reasons that people might be
in a dark place alcohol or drugs or
failure of relationships or lack of
vision or nihilism or or hopelessness or
depression or anxiety if you know all
the pitfalls that people can encounter
and I've been developing a vision for my
life and trying to adopt responsibility
and trying to be careful with what I say
and things are way better
and that's what drives me what's your
definition of greatness
well greatness is what reveals itself
when you
when you attempt to formulate when you
attempt to carefully articulate and live
out what you believe to be true
it just happens because there isn't
anything more powerful than truth
right that's the antidote to suffering
truth
right
so it's a strange thing because you
think well yeah it produces a lot of
suffering too it's like yeah in the
short term they say Do you believe in
god let's say and my response to that
always is well I don't know what you
mean when you ask me that question so I
don't know how to answer it I don't know
what you mean by believe but I can tell
you something that I believe and I would
say this is a way of speaking
symbolically
I do believe so I was thinking the other
day a week ago I was thinking about this
this little fantasy that entered my mind
I was thinking about Saint Joseph's
oratorio in Montreal and St Joseph's
oratorio is a very large religious
building it's one of the biggest
cathedral-like structures in the world
and it's set on the hill on Mount Royal
and it's set up where it can catch the
sun you know so it's an image of the
Heavenly City on the hill right it's an
image of the structures that we strive
to create that's what it is independent
of its specifically Christian or
religious function that's what it stands
for symbolically okay so it's the city
on the hill it's it's what we're
striving towards when we walk uphill
in life okay now the way the the
oratorio is structured there's hundreds
of steps leading to it up front and in
the early part of the 20th century a lot
of people who had physical disabilities
came there and they struggled up the
step on their crutches and many of them
left their crutches in the oratorio you
can see hundreds of them if you go there
it's quite an interesting site and I was
thinking about that and I was thinking
about what that meant and this is what
it means it means that
you know everyone has their disabilities
let's say and I know that some people
are far more terribly affected than
other people I'm perfectly aware of that
but the question is what do you do about
that and what you do is you you set
yourself up on your crutches and you
struggle up the bloody Hill that's what
you do and you struggle up the hill
towards the kingdom of God that's what
you do because the alternative is to
descend into the abyss that's the
alternative and then so to say well do
you believe it's like I believe that you
should struggle uphill towards the city
of God on your crutches
that's what you should do
that's the opposite of the descent into
the abyss
and so that's that's at the foundation
of our civilization that idea well argue
with it if you will see if you can
figure out why that's not an acceptable
idea maybe you should help someone
struggle up the hill perhaps you should
you know you can lend a hand to someone
although you don't want to take the
burden away from them entirely because
there's something Noble about struggling
up the hill right there's something
that's Adventure that's the call to
proper being it's like well we don't
need to forget this
you know we don't need to forget it the
universities have been there since time
immemorial to try to push that idea
forward through the generations and
everyone needs to know that idea that's
what gives your life not happiness
forget about that
if it comes well great accept it I made
a decision when the computers started to
become omnipresent and so that would
have been about 1993 that I was going to
spend a year and that was the first year
that I was teaching in Boston pretty
much doing nothing but figuring out how
Intel 486 has worked and it meant there
was a lot of other things that I had to
put on hold but I did become a competent
computer user and I was I'm pretty fast
but you know my son it's just annoying
as hell to watch him on the computer and
on the phone because and my graduate
students as well because they're so much
faster than me that it's not even funny
and I'm not really accustomed to being
slower than someone else in the room you
know if I had children now the one thing
I would bloody well make sure that they
knew was how to use a computer how to
program man because if you're smart and
you can use a computer you are so much
smarter than you are if you're just
smart that it's not even funny you know
and you talk to people you see this in
Silicon Valley all the time you talk to
people who are expert computer users
they are so bloody powerful it is just
beyond belief so and that that's going
to do nothing but expand right because
Moore's Law is not dead and computers
are doubling in power every 18 months
and and so and who the hell knows where
that's going to go I don't know what
percentage of human effort is spent in
counterproductive activity you know I
I'm I'm not an absolute cynic about that
but I mean when I talk to undergraduates
I ask them you know how much time do you
waste every day by your own
Reckoning and it's somewhere between
five and eight hours you know it's a lot
of it's a lot of time well I usually
walk through I walk the students through
an economic analysis of that I said well
you know why don't you value your time
at fifty dollars an hour and calculate
for yourself just exactly what you're
doing to your future by your inability
to discipline yourself it's worth
thinking through
in any case people do waste a lot of
time and they are they also act
counterproductively a lot of the time
the other thing you should do if you're
not very industrious industrious is
discipline yourself and so what do you
do with that
eat three times a day at regular meal
times that's a good thing to practice
because that starts to put some
stability into your life get up at the
same time I would highly recommend all
those young people out there who are
listening like you want to get a jump on
life get the hell out of bed in the
morning you know as I've got older I've
got up earlier and earlier now that's
partly because you don't need as much
sleep but it's also partly because I've
got more and more discipline like get up
early in the morning and get your things
done man learn to get up at six in the
morning and you'll be one deadly
creature especially if you can get to
work you'll have half your day done by
the time other people haul their sorry
asses out of bed and so that's a massive
massive Advantage look Will Ferrell
Warren Farrell not the comedian Warren
Farrell the author he outlined data in
why men earn more which is a book I
would recommend by the way showing that
if you work 13 longer hours you make
forty percent more money
it's non-linear so you think why is that
well imagine you had 10 employees and
one of them Works an extra 10 percent
it's not much well how often is that
person going to be
promoted assuming you have a clue as a
boss it's like you're going to look at
the 10 people and you're going to think
oh that guy's always here like 45
minutes early it's like why don't we
give him the promotion obviously right
so these tie these small edges that you
can manage like that work an extra 10 or
extra 13 have non-proportional payoffs
that's part of the Pareto distribution
so
get
get your sleep cycle organized so you
get up in the morning learn how to do it
no excuses I'm too tired in the morning
I don't like mornings who cares that's
not relevant it's like discipline
yourself so you can manage it
schedule your meals because that's a
good disciplinary routine
and then learn to use a calendar like
Google Calendar most of you many of you
out there do not use a calendar okay a
calendar is not a prison and it's not a
tyrant not if you use it properly
a calendar keeps anxiety at Bay it makes
sure that you do what you need to do
which is important because otherwise you
fall behind but if you use it properly
though it's also helps you plan what you
want to do so I could say well lay out
your calendar
and design the days you would like to
have that's what your calendars have is
for so you can put in all sorts of
things in there you want to do and that
would be good for you and that's a
really good a really good way to start
being more industrious make a plan you
need a plan for three years
you need a plan for the next year you
need to plan for the next six months you
need to plan for the next three months
you need a plan for the week you need a
plan for the day you need to plan for
the hour all of that all of that I make
lists constantly of what I have to do
and they're like daily weekly monthly
yearly right now I can't look out more
than about six months you know because
my life is too complicated and chaotic
but but you need a vision of who you
could be what character you could have
three to five years out you can't go
much farther than that because life is
too unpredictable I think to make Vision
that's longer term than that
subject to
there's too too much chance associated
with it to spend a lot of time on maybe
you can stretch it to five years and in
rare cases you can have a 10-year goal
but it has to be pretty low resolution
but you want plans at all those levels
of resolution you want to write the
things down and what because what are
you going to do you're going to stumble
around and get get what you need you're
going to stumble around and be useful to
other people and it's useful to be
useful to other people you know they
want to work with you then they want to
do things with you they want to have you
around they trust you they open up
opportunities for you and if you stumble
around like you're blind you're not
going to get anywhere and then you're
going to suffer and then you're going to
be bitter and then you're going to be
cruel so that's a bit that's hell that's
a bad outcome because you made it this
far in a video I want to celebrate you
most people start and don't finish most
people never actually follow through
most people say they want something but
they don't ever do the work to actually
get it but you're different you are
special believe Nation you made it here
all the way to the end and I love you so
as a special celebration if you put a
hashtag believe down in the comments
Below on this video I will showcase you
and celebrate you somewhere on the
screen in a future video because you are
awesome
if you want another amazing Jordan
Peterson video check it out right there
next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there